يسعدني ان ييسر اعمل هذه الجلسه ارحب
بالحاضرين معنا
والمشاركين معنا بشكل الافتراضي ان كنتم
تستخدمون
وسائط الاعلام الاجتماعي
اريد ان اقول لكم في بدايه هذه الجلسه
اننا عندما نتطرق الى شرق الاوسط نتناول
مشاكل المشكله التي لم تختفي ولم تتلاشى
بعد الجائحه الصحيه التي عيشناها همم
لاحظنا ان هناك مخيفات في مستوى ونسبه همم
هذه التوترات التي تشهدها المنطقه لكن
صراعات لا تزال قائمه كيف يمكن ان نخفف من
معاناته اولئك الاشخاص الذين يفتقرون الى
الصوت والصدى وكيف نستطيع ان نتناول
المشاكل التي تعيشها المنطقه بصفه سيده
اصل انها عايره عراقيه يشتوا الحرب
العراقيه واعرف انه منذ ذلك اللحين وحتى
يومنا هذا كانت لدينا فتره تماما مكنتنا
من ان نقيم ما الذي حدث في المنطقه
وعالميا ااه هناك
منطقه معنيين بما يحدث من حولينا ونتاثر
بما يحدث من حولنا على مستوى الطاقه على
مستوى همم
معي صاحب
السموات همم
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
النائب رئيس الوزراء العراقي معنى سيد
محمد القسيس وزير الماليه الاردني ومعنى
وزيره الدفاع الهولنديه سيده كاشا اوغرانو
ومعنى المبعوث الخاص
للامم المتحده عن اليمن السيد هانس كراند
صاحب السموح رايتم همم
فترات همم شهدت فيها المنطقه همم
عمليات مصالحه وفتره اخرى شهيده التوترات
كبيره ما رايكم في كل ذلك همم اريد ان
اعود الى عنوان هذه الجلسه
الشرق الاوسط نقطه انطلاق او ساحه معركه
نرى ان همم منطقه الشرق نقطه انطلاق بين
الغرب والشرق حاليا همم قررنا ان او دخلنا
قرارنا بان نكون جسرا يربط بين الغرب
والشر هناك الكثير من النشاطات الايجابيه
الجاريه في المنطقه بالرغم من التحديات
التي لازلنا نواجهها ان المملكه العربيه
السعوديه همم هي من الاقتصادات هذا العام
واا بالتعاوني مع شركائنا مثل العراق
والاردن الممثلتين هنا حول هذه الطاوله
نقوم باطلاق مشاريع قوى مهطره بوت في مجال
الطاقه وغير ذلك هناك روحيه تعاون سائده
في المنطقه
وروحيه التعاون هذه يمكن ان تكون معديه هو
يمكن ان تعزز ما يتبقى من فوارق ونزاعات
في المنطقه فعندما نتحدث عن علاقتنا مثلا
مع بعض جيراننا همم دائما
نركز على همم ونقول ونرك ونركز على ان
الناس استثمر في المستقبل نستثمر من اجل
ازدهاري همم المنطقه ككل وليس فقط المملكه
العربيه السعوديه الى نحن نذهب في هذا
الاتجاه عندما تحدث مع زملائي وحتى مع
رجال الاعمال همم
يتبين للجميع ان هناك فعلا طاقه في
المنطقه همم وهذا ما تراه الاسره الدوليه
وليد نرى التساما من قبل بلدان العالم من
خلالها تعدد المبادرات متعدده الاطراف لان
الهدف هو ان نتمكن من ان نواكب هذه
المنطقه الا هذه الفتره الهامه جدا
لمنطقهتنا
اهميه هذه المشاريع التي من شانها ان تسمح
لنا بان نتشارك في المستقبل
معا اي مشاريع تتحدث همم
يثير حماستي هي رؤيه
لعام30 همم
رؤيه همم لعام 2000 وثلاثين
ستسمح ببناء اقتصاد المنطقه ككل وليس فقط
همم اقتصاد المملكه العربيه السعوديه همم
اذا يتعلق الامر فعلا بالاستثمار
بنائي اسس همم
الاقتصاد المستدامه همم
نحتاجه بالتالي الى منطقه همم مامونه لكي
نطوره اقتص ان سمحنا لجيراننا بنائي
اقتصاديات الصلب قويه هذا سيسمح بتحقيق
الازدهار في كافه ارجاء المنطقه نتعاون مع
الجميع مع العراق مع الاردن ومع كافه
جيراننا في المنطقه هناك لجان مشتركه شكلت
لعمل على اهداف محدده
وقياده بلادنا همم
تفضل عدم الاقتصار على مجلد الشعارات بل
تفضل ان يصارع العمل وفقا لاهداف محدده
ملموسه هناك مشاريع جمع في المملكه ونرى
ان همم مصر والاردن والعراق تعمل تعمل مع
بعضها البعض همم في اطار مبادرات متعدده
الاطراف اذا هناك العديد من المبادرات
المتعدده الاطراف
لبناء ساره مشتركه لنا جميعا
امم من المواضيع الهامه الموضوع اليمني
وهنا
حاليا اليمن ستكون سلسله يتجزا من هذا
العمل الجاري في المنطقه كيف يمكنها الحرب
لا يمكن انها الحرب الا من خلال
حلل يتم الاتفاق عليه وهذا ما ما نعمل
عليه حاليا ف مبعوث الخاص همم
للامم المتحده للمعني باليمن معنا على هذه
الطاوله حكومه اليمن ايضا همم تسعى الى
ايجاده همم سبيل له لايجاد اتفاقا مع
الحوثيين
للوصول الى انتهاء لوقف اطلاق النار
والوصولي الى انهاء لهاتيه همم
اذا احببتنا تقدما لكن لا يزال الطريق
طويل
او مدى التقدم المحرز
سامسونج سامسونج
[موسيقى]
وابي سليم
نقطه التقاء ام انها ساحه معركه برايي
الشيخ الاوسط يمكن ان تكون منطقه الالتقاء
طبعا هناك صعوبات تترقي اليها صاحب السمو
هناك الصراعات ومن بينها سيرا اليمني همم
يجب حلول لهذه المشاكل والصراعات هل
احرزنا همم تقدما ايجابيا نعم خلال الاشهر
الاخيره القليله احرزنا تطورات او تقدما
ايجابيه همم
الماضي لكن لا يجب ان يخلي لنا ان الموضوع
قد انتهى لكن الخطوات التي احرزناها كانت
ايجابيه خطوات الى الامام
اخي لا لا الاشهر الاخيره همم
انخفض صوت السلاح لكن طبعا
اذا لم ينتهي تنتهي المشكله بعد لكننا
نذهب في الاتجاه القويم ااا التطورات
الاخيره جعلت اليمنيين يشعرون بان هناك
امكانيه لوصولي هذا الصراع الى
النهايه همم محموده
[موسيقى]
طبعا يسعدني ان ارى انه هناك اطراف عده
موجوده هنا وتشارك في الجهود المبذوله همم
فهناك جهود مكثفه بدلت مؤخرا لهذه الغايه
وانا سعيد بذلك الهدف هو ان نتمكن من ان
نحقق ما هو مطلوب اليمن اي الوصول الى
اعتمادي مسار سياسيا شامل
وايجابي لايجادي حل للصراع لكن لا يسعني
الا وان اتوجه بالشكر والامتنان الى
المملكه الاردنيه
[موسيقى]
تمام
ههه
الينا بان ايجاد حل لسراع اليمني هو
بالعمر السهل اااا لكن علينا ان نعمل في
هذا الاتجاه بالرغم من كل صعوباته شكرا
بالنسبه الى هذا الموضوع هنا كاهنا قائمه
مهلك
[موسيقى]
مش في اليمن درويش
التي تعترض سبيلنا لكن لو تمكنا من اقناع
الحوثيين وحكومه اليمن لو تمكنا من
اقناعهم بتوسل الى وقف الاطلاق النار فهذا
سيفتح الباب امام التقدم السياسي الامارات
العربيه المتحده
ماساويه
المرور سنه على العمليه الارهابيه التي
شهدتها البلاد اريد ان اسالكم عن الاثر
الاقليمي لليمن على عملكم همم
اليمنيين طبعا
دوت
لحظه التفاؤل هذه هي لحظه ربما هل يتشارك
بها العديد في المنطقه ام لا
كل بلدان المنطقه
الخليج
كل هذه البلدان تعتبر
فعلا
النظر
عن المكان الذي تتواجد فيه وانت تنظر الى
احداث اليمن والتطورات
لدي علاقات جيده مع جميع البلدان
المجاوره لليمن
[موسيقى]
همم كيف همم وعلى اي اسس هذه امور يمكن ان
نتفاوض بشانها لكن هناك دعم ااا من
المنطقه دعم مقدم ايضا من الاسره الدوليه
جمعاء بما في تلك بلدان مثل هولندا التي
تطلع بدور ناشط في بعض
المجلات الخاصه بيسرع اليمني ايضا
الى
[موسيقى]
العراقين ايضا منتدى بغداد
مع الاردن مؤخرا ااه ما عليكم اريد ان
اعرف ما هو دور العراق وكيف تستمر العراق
ببناء سياستها الخارجيه في وقت لا تزال
البلدان المجاوره الصعوبات
العام 2003
[موسيقى]
بهذه الدي يا ولا فيه تاعها لابد من ان
يترافق ذلك مع بعض المشاكل هناك تفاعل
كبير بين السياسه الداخليه والسياسه
الخارجيه وتحدث هنا عن السياسه الاقليميه
بنسبه الى الشؤون السياسيه الداخليه
والصراعات ضمن المجتمع العراقي او على
مستوى السياسه العراقيه نجد حلول وطرق
لمعالجه هذه المشاكل التي تتعلق داخل
العراق
في نهايه المطاف
وبعد تدرس الوضع يتبين لنا ان هناك كرابط
بين سياسه داخليه وساسه الاقليميه
تفاعل كبير جدا بين الكلى
[موسيقى]
المشاكل المتعلقه بالسياسه الداخليه خارجه
حدودنا
المشاكل بها العراق العراق
كما تعرفون لديها علاقه جديده مع كافه
جيرانها ومن الممكن للعراق ان تتواصل مع
جميع البلدان المجاوره
في الشده المواضيع سواء كان ذلك على
المستوى الثنائي
ببغداد
[موسيقى]
وتؤثر داخل على داخل العراق
لتحقيق هذا الامن الاقليمي العراق العراق
بهذا الدور
فبلادنا همم تحاول ان تجمع الجميع ونحن
ساعدونا بالاطلاع بهذا الدور هناك صحفيون
يعتبرون او يقولون بان اللقاءات
والاجتماعات هم جدا لكن لابناء الثقه
نحتاج الى همم
مباحثات لكن ماذا بعد العراق لا تزال
تعانيه هناك هشومات لا تزلت شن هناك
انقطاع في تزويد بالموارد المائيه وغيرها
من المشاكل كيف يمكن تعزيز امن العراق
وتحسين وضع البلاد العلاقه بين العراق
وتركيا وبين بغداد وطهران همم هي علاقات
مرتبطه
الجغرافيا وبالتاريخ
وبالمصالح الاقتصاديه
عندما يكون هناك مشاكل
عندما ننظر الى تاريخ العراق يتبين لنا ان
العراق
[موسيقى]
عندما هاشمت تركيا الاراضي العراقيه
والعمر سيان بالنسبه الى الايرانيين كيف
نتعامل مع حالات كهذه
السياسيه
المتواجده داخل العراق
[موسيقى]
وضعنا الداخلي يمنعنا
تشكيله
تنظم وتتشكل على اراضينا وتكون سياستها
مغيره الوطنيه
هذه المشاكل
داخليه
[موسيقى]
في العراق
اليوم الامر نفسه وهو يا ابو الصبي الامل
والتفاؤل في صدورنا
ولكن ايضا علينا ان
نقر بان هناك مشاكل
وتوترات يجب حلها من خلال الحوار ومن خلال
الاستمراري على هذا الزخم الزخم في
التعاون الاقليمي نقول فيه هولندا من
المهم جدا ان يكون لدينا
جار جيد من صديق بعيد وهذا ما نريده اليوم
الاستقراره في الشرق الاوسط ينصب مصلحه
علينا جميعا امور كثيره تحدث في العالم قد
يظن البعض اننا نحن في اوروبا نركز على
الحرب في اوكرانيا اكثر من اي موضوع اخر
نعم هذا صحيح ولكن في نفس الوقت لا ننسى
الشرق الاوسط لدينا
شركاتنا في الشرق الاوسط ايضا بالنسبه الى
العراق
سبورتاج
تحت قياده المتحده نحاربه داعش واليوم
وصلنا الى مرحله دعم الاستقرار واصبحنا
نركز اكثر على مساعده
في بناء هذا الاحتراف الامنيه في العراق
ذات اهميه كبيره بالنسبه الينا هو مشروع
على الامر الطويل والامر يعود الى السلطات
العراقيه ان تقرر شكلها هذا التعاون ومدته
نحن متواجدون اصدقاء للعراق
بسبب ايماننا بالعراق ما هو تهديد داعش
اليوم لازالات داعش تشكل وتهديدا كبيرا
ولكن ليست بنفسه الحجم الذي كان يشكله في
السابقات والخلايا النائمه الداعشيه
وعلينا ان نلقي اعيننا مفتوحه عليها
والقوات الامنيه العراقيه تتولى هذا
الموضوع بشكل جيد اسمحي لي ان اعلق لو
سمحت اولا
اتقدموا بالشكر الى الحكومه
الهولنديه التي تدعم المسار الامنيه
العراقيه كجزء من التحالف الاكبر ضد داعش
قاموا بعمل رائع اثناء الحرب ضد داعش
والان في تقديم المشهوره والتدريب
القوات الامنيه
والعسكريه في العراق اما بالنسبه الى داعش
تغير شكل التهديد
ما يعرف بالدوله الاسلاميه
[موسيقى]
همم ده فيدت
الخلفيه
لداعش لا زلت قائمه من الناحيه العسكريه
طبعا
تمت قمعهم ولكن من الناحيه الايديولوجيه
لا زال علينا ان نقوم بالكثير لكي نحارب
هذه الجيولوجيات لانه بامكانهن يعيد تنظيم
انفسهم
ليس فقط على العراق على الشرق الاوساط من
المهم جدا بالتالي هذا التعاون وان نستمر
فقط
عراقي هو دون الخامسه عشر من عمره وهي
بالتلهي هو بلد شاب وهنا ننتقل للحديث عن
المال وعن خلق اا الفرس راينا زخما هنا
كيف من الممكن ان نترجم ذلك لكي يشعر
الناس في الشرق الاوسط السؤال
الوزير الاردني
الشرق الادنى واليوم اصبحنا الشرق الاوسط
التسمي بحدي ذاتها يجب ان تتغير اليوم نحن
نتقدم نحو الاستقرار
وتحدثنا عندها على الانتقال من الدول
الداخليه الى الدول الكليه
الكثيره من التغيرات وصلنا في نهايتها الى
الحرب على اوكرانيا
ولازلنا نعمل معه
السوداء اليوم وصلنا الى الباجات السوداء
مع ثلاث هجمات اقتصاديه عالميه لازلنا
نشهد اثارها اليوم لابد لنا ان نحضرنا
انفسنا لهذه الصدمات على انها هي
الواقع المعتاد
ابقينا الاقتصاد للنهايه
المشكله
اقتصادي
الى ترجمه
ماليه عانى في فتره التضخم والجائحه اركز
على على الاستقرار الكلي الذي سيؤدي الى
الاستقرار الجزئي
منتجانبيه
الاسر ان تؤمن
بانده
من مستوى عيشهم هم هم
كثيره منعتنا من الحلم بمستقبل علينا ان
نستعد هذا الزخم ان نستملك مستقبلنا ان
يكون مستقبلنا افضل نعم نعم في نفسي
المكان ولكن تغيرت
الظروف
[موسيقى]